speaking of presidents by the way just
in case you were sleeping too soundly at
night i would like to give you some
nightmares
meghan markle the erstwhile duchess of
sussex
is reportedly networking with top
democratic party leaders and
mulling a bid for the u.s presidency in
2024
this according to the daily mail which
cites an unnamed
british labour party official
is this true do i believe this
i don't believe generally the things i
read in the papers but given the
sort of given the fact that meghan
markle
got her husband to leave his family his
royal family
move back to america and she's
constantly courting fame
and public favor yeah wouldn't be
shocked i don't know stranger things
have happened she believes that biden
who will be 82 in 2024 might not run for
a second term fair enough
uh megan's biographer and longtime
friend
omid scoby has claimed that the actress
quote has her eyes set on the u.s
presidency
first of all why does meghan markle have
a biographer
this is news to me that she i guess the
fact that it's
the guy's a friend of hers would make
sense because she's like hey get me get
me a biography i'm trying to run for
office
on the one hand this seems far-fetched
on another
meghan markle is the voice of a
generation
she is she is the classic millennial
woman millennial person
who would rather pretend to be a
princess
on disney then be an actual princess
she would rather have the appearance of
the thing
right that she would rather have the
perks and the privileges of the thing
rather than the substance of the thing
big divide between
left and right and i think uh a big
marker of the millennial generation
meghan markle is no less qualified to be
president than aoc
right aoc is a clever politician meghan
markle's a clever politician
aoc doesn't know nothing about nothing
with regard to say
history philosophy
geopolitics but neither does the other
one
neither markle nor aoc really know
anything about that sort of stuff
hasn't hampered either of their
political careers and meghan markle is a
politician meghan markle
is an extraordinarily gifted politician
meghan markle nabbed herself a prince
and meghan markle not only nabbed
herself a prince
she convinced him to leave the palaces
the castles the country that his family
symbolizes and move with her
to l.a right i think they're living in
l.a
it's a city that i fled l.a not a not a
great place right now
convinced prince harry to move with her
to california
to do what so that she could like do
voiceovers for disney
there's a great clip of harry begging
some entertainment ceos but
you know you might hire my wife to do
some voice over work yes
so that she can be an actress that's
pretty powerful political skill
is megan coming up in 2024 maybe
it'd be hard to imagine that kamala
harris who is a really skillful
politician
which i've said from the very beginning
i said early on in 2016 i heard 2020
rather i said
watch out for kamala harris she's a
shark and then it seemed like
my prediction was totally wrong because
she was the first to drop out but i
think i was actually vindicated because
she more than anyone else on that stage
other than joe biden
has been able to amass political power
and frankly maybe more so than joe biden
because
i think very few people believe joe's
actually running anything over there
at the white house if you enjoyed that
break from disinformation
historical revision and screaming about
the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button so
that you never miss another video